ننا المخيم عننا كل شبابنا اسرى كل دار
فيها اسير كل دار فيها شهيد ماخلو حدا
فينا يعني هم اللي تعدوا علينا احنا في
دورنا قاعدين يعني المخيم له فتره رايق ما
بوي شيء ما شاء الله هم اللي بيجوا علينا
هم اللي بيتعدوا هم بيدمروا في دورنا يعني
بدخلوا بدهم اسير خربوا العفش خربوا الدور
خربوا حتى الثلاجات الغسالات الكله بدمر
كل شيء ما بخلوا شيء احنا من حقنا ندافع
عن نفسنا هم وخلص اخذوا كل شيء شو اللي
بدهم اياه الارض اخذو بدهم ا خلص يفكوا
عنا كل دار فيها اسير انا ابني اسير
الشهيد له اسير اخوه سنه له هي اخذ واحد
اليوم يعني بس الحمد لله صامدين الحمد لله
بحمد الله احنا مش احسن من غزه غزه الله
يعينها احنا واقفين مع غزه اصلا في كل
دعاء في كل صباح في الليل وفي النهار ما
منوم عن التلفزيونات واحنا بستب اهل غزه
خلص شو بدهم اياه بدهم اه هول
الاحتلال
ه